Monkey D Luffy is known for humiliating
opponents throughout one piece unless
he's fighting one of these 11 characters
for someone who's a Shonen protagonist
and really should have the thickest plot
armor in history Luffy has actually been
defeated at least 11 times one of them
is a major surprise one is almost as
controversial as the Zoro versus Sanji
debate and the remaining ones all follow
the same 4 simple step formula that
makes one piece so amazing like the time
that Luffy got defeated and almost
captured by his Arc Nemesis smoker
before even properly starting his
Adventure Luffy traveled to an island
called loketown where Goldie Roger the
first pirate king was both born and
ultimately executed here Luffy runs into
the Marine Captain smoker who recognizes
him from his first bouncy poster that he
received after beating Arlon smoker is
the first character introduced with the
powers of a low-year devil fruit power
that turns his body into smoke making
him completely immune to any physical
attacks as a result Luffy has no chance
whatsoever against the marine and is
defeated in an instant he's only spared
because his father Dragon steps in to
stop smoker and as a result Luffy is
then able to proceed unscathed with his
crew towards the grand line now the
pattern that aichiro Oda the author of
One Piece uses here are the same four
steps that he uses with every single
opponent that has been able to beat
Luffy he first introduces the villain in
a really impressive way showing just how
powerful and Superior they are and then
have them defeat Luffy in this case
Luffy not Landing one single hit on
smoker and being pinned down then in the
Second Step Luffy barely manages to
escape the situation like here for
instance with dragon stepping in to save
his son in the third step this gives
Luffy the necessary drive to grow and be
creative either as a person or in terms
of power to overcome this newfound
obstacle in this case Luffy learns that
he can't beat every single enemy he
faces and that sometimes you simply have
to run away and come back stronger which
then leads to step number four Luffy
succeeding in his original Mission like
in this case making it successfully to
the entrance of the grand line you can
see the exact same formula with Luffy's
third major defeat in the story as well
when he encounters another Marine this
time one of the three most powerful
Marines in the story The Admiral aokiji
and he is one of the most powerful
characters in the entire story period
aokiji just like smoker is a logia fruit
user whose entire body is made out of
ice and who can't take physical damage
without an ability called hockey that
Luffy only learns way later on in the
story and so with Luffy having no way of
dealing any damage to his opponent once
again he is frozen solid by Aoki Jeep
step number one however as we learn a
little bit later in the story aokiji is
more of an ally than an enemy to the
straw hat crew he just wanted to test
Luffy's resolve and if he was actually
worthy of watching over Nico Robin a
girl who has been chased and hunted her
entire life and that aokiji had saved as
a kiss before he doesn't actually
capture or kill Luffy but spares his
life which is how Luffy step number two
escapes here now even though aokiji
tells him that he should send Nico Robin
away because she will only bring a lot
of trouble to him again this was all a
test Luffy has already accepted her as
part of his family step 3 and is able to
proceed towards water 7 to get his ship
fixed step number four and speaking of
water 7 Luffy has his butt kicked again
there by another official from the world
government which is the organization
that leads the Marines and rules the
entire world who in this case want to
capture Nico Robin for her knowledge
about the Lost history that they're
trying to keep hidden from the public
the antagonist here the government agent
Luchi has eaten the leopard devil fruit
that gives him the ability of the animal
plus superhuman strength and endurance
and so the leopard's incredible speed
combined with the six special techniques
known by each of the government's top
secret agents makes him the first
opponent in the story that Luffy could
actually touch in theory but who's
simply physically too fast and strong
and as a result Luffy is utterly
humiliated in his fight the difference
in power is so bad that Luchi has no
interest in finishing Luffy off at all
and instead simply tosses him out of the
building before he leaves the island
with the captured Robin and therefore
Luffy survives once again this time in
order to save his crew member he trains
hard and develops two new techniques for
his devil fruit that allow him to defeat
Luchi in one of the best fights of the
series and as a result of this he
ultimately manages to liberate Robin in
my personal favorite moment of the
entire show now you might or might not
have realized that I actually skipped
one of Luffy's major defeats here
against the warlord crocodile during the
alabaster Saga and Luffy didn't just
lose once against him but actually twice
just like smoke and aokiji crocodile is
also a logia devil fruit user who is
made of sand thus once again Luffy's
punches do nothing and he is gruesomely
impaled this time he only survives
thanks to Robin's help who is still an
enemy at this point but I do hope that
you see just how nicely all of these
defeats are kind of linked together here
in this case simply getting stronger
won't be enough so Luffy has to actually
use his imagination and creativity to
overcome this enemy he has noticed
previously that his fist covered in his
own blood can actually deal damage to
crocodile since Sans weakness is
moisture so for his rematch he brings a
barrel of water to the fight and manages
to take crocodile out that way this
allows him to save the kingdom of
alabaster and also free Nico Robin from
her dark past as well dark like the
dwelling place of the fifth character
that manages to defeat Luffy and this
one might come as a bit of a surprise
even if you've already watched up to
this point I mean I definitely didn't
remember that this happened at first on
Thriller bark Luffy faces Gekko Moria
one of the seven Warlords of the scene
who are powerful Pirates working with
the government that has the unique
ability to steal people's shadows and
Infuse dead objects with them now this
stuff feed was really sneaky but as
Luffy and Co were infiltrating the
spooky Castle they got trapped in a room
with countless of Moria zombies who had
already managed to take zoro's Shadow
away and while Luffy was busy facing the
zombie who now had zoro's powers and
personality he was overwhelmed by tiny
little Spider-Man zombies who managed to
seal him inside a coffin so that morya
could now steal his shadow too and
Infuse it into the ancient giant ores
that should be completely fair this was
not exactly a 1v1 in this case but
morya's entire character Arc was
centered around letting others do the
dirty work for him plus it was his devil
fruit ability that took Luffy out so I
do think it counts Luffy once again
managed to escape however he infused
himself with hundreds of Shadows and
becomes nightmare Luffy still one of the
coolest forms he has ever taken in the
story and manages to take back his
shadow and defeat morya but while this
defeat might have been the most
surprising that Luffy has ever
experienced it is nothing against what
happens next traveling from through the
park to the next island called Saba ODI
archipelago Luffy and the crew
experienced their most crushing defeat
yet Luffy attacks one of the world
Nobles the rulers of the world who was
trying to buy his mermaid friend Jaime
as a slave now punching a Celestial
Dragon is the highest crime anyone can
commit in the one piece world and so the
government sends over another one of the
three top Marine Admirals this time it's
not aokiji but someone called kizaru who
ate the light lokia fruit once again
making him an enemy that Luffy can't
beat but on top of that there's also
Kuma and centomaru who decimate the
entire crew now at this point Luffy
doesn't know yet that's similar to
aokiji Kuma actually does this to
protect Luffy and the others from being
captured or killed by kizaru and so that
way Luffy once again escapes by being
teleported to another Island however
interestingly enough in this case the
growth from this defeat doesn't really
happen right away making this a cure
serious exception to the entire list so
far instead Luffy finds out that his
brother Ace has been captured and is
about to be executed by the Marines so
he goes off on a mission to free him
from the hellish government prison
called imple down the main antagonist
here is Magellan the warden of the
prison that has eaten the poison poison
fruit that allows him to produce and
manipulate any poison imaginable
Magellan stands out from the list in his
own way as he not only defeated Luffy
without any effort at all but also
Blackbeard and his entire crew as they
were infiltrating the prison in this
case Luffy only barely manages to
survive his deadly poisoning thanks to
you being subscribed to the channel and
also his newly made Ally ivankov whose
abilities save Luffy's life here at this
point Luffy becomes immune to pretty
much all poisons Hereafter and manages
to make it out of the prison and towards
Marine Forge the Marines headquarters
where his brother has been taken to be
executed however here at the Marine
headquarters amidst the biggest war in
the history of one piece so far Luffy
experiences the biggest defeat in the
entire story which results in the lowest
point of his journey to the point where
he almost gives up his will to live
altogether now just to put it out there
Luffy isn't defeated only once during
this war he's surrounded by characters
way out of his league but through sheer
will alone and with the help of all the
Newfound allies that he's made he
actually manages to free his brother
from his shackles however ultimately
akinu the strongest and cruelest of the
three Admirals is the one defeating
Luffy here Akino who has this powerful
crazy magma logia ability now the only
reason his life is paired once again
here is because Luffy's brother and
jimbei both sacrifice themselves for him
it's the first and only time so far in
the story where Luffy doesn't succeed in
his mission during an arc he wanted to
save his brother and fails which as a
result automatically makes it the most
impactful event of one piece to this day
however Luffy did learn from his defeat
and inspired him to become a better
Captain who can properly take care of
his crew and taught him that you can't
always expect things to just
miraculously work out without any
consequences and even better to give
Luffy a major payoff and win after this
gigantic loss after a two-year time skip
period full of training and new
abilities Luffy is now not only able to
beat the Posse fista that he had so much
trouble with on Saba ODI before but he's
now also able to use haki the ability
necessary to fight against logia type
users like smoker crocodile or any of
the three Admirals which makes the next
character that manages to defeat Luffy
just the more surprising the crazy
scientist sees a clown who rules over
the apocalyptic Island Punk Hazard is
another logia fruit user his body is
made entirely out of gas now Luffy is
able to survive Caesar's initial poison
gas attack ethically quite questionable
by the way thanks to his poison immunity
that he gained from the prison but then
the scientists remove all the air from
the room since oxygen is also a gas and
thus makes Luffy pass out very clever
fighting I gotta say now Luffy once
again manages to get away easily with
the help of his new Ally the warlord's
Trafalgar law Luffy has now learned from
his earlier mistake and this time takes
out Caesar in a quite satisfying manner
not quite as satisfying though as
against this next enemy that managed to
defeat Luffy here this is probably the
most controversial and maybe most unique
candidate on this list Charlotte
katakuri is the strongest pirate in the
crew of the emperor big mom one of the
four strongest Pirates Who ruled this
part of the world now karakuri has eaten
the mochi mochi fruit Mochi being sticky
Japanese rice cake and his fruit is
pretty much the same as Luffy's rub
abilities only that katakuri is way
better at using it he also has way
better hockey abilities and overall
simply outclasses Luffy by Miles he
completely dominates their fight to such
an extent that Luffy gets as frustrated
as we haven't seen him for a long long
time in the story he even Escapes in the
middle of the battle to think about his
strategy and how he can actually catch
up to katakuri katakuri Meanwhile slowly
starts to like Luffy and pushes him to
grow stronger until he's actually
powerful enough to defeat him now there
is a very strong argument to be made
here whether or not katakuri actually
let Luffy beat him on purpose or not but
it is without any question that katakuri
beat Luffy initially during the first
half of the fight and that the battle
followed the exact same four stages as
all the other defeats as a result Luffy
learns to use his devil fruit way more
creatively and even gains the ability to
look slightly ahead into the future but
surprisingly enough this is nothing
against what Luffy learned from his
battle with kaido one of the four
Emperors said to be the strongest
creature on the planet and Luffy's
introduction to kaido is a defeat that's
over with a single hit I mean Luffy
might never have been as outclassed as
in this fight he has to go on an entire
training Arc and escape from prison in
order to even take kaido on a second
time and is beaten again this time Luffy
is saved by his devil fruit powers and
his will to live as a result however he
grows immensely as both a leader and a
fighter to the point where he emerges as
one of the strongest people in the
entire story so really there aren't too
many characters left now who would have
a chance of beating Luffy this guy
however is a completely different story
Blackbeard is the main antagonist of the
story so far and will be Luffy's biggest
obstacle in the way of becoming pirate
king if you want to know just how
powerful he is and why he's able to
wield on one but two devil fruits as the
only character in the entire story well
you can watch this video right here next